>> And, in fact, we can simplify this even further by replacing this with a
special symbol and replacing these with something shorter. The symbol we'll use
for sum, is this, sigma. And instead of writing out the whole salary of
Geography majors, we'll just calls this x. And instead of writing out number of
Geography majors, we'll just call this n, for number. So now, we have a really
nice formula for the mean, x bar equals the sum of x divided by n. Isn't that
pretty? Now remember, this is for a sample, and you saw in Lesson 1 that the
sample statistic is denoted by x bar. For a population, we denote it by mu. And
again, we can say it's the sum of x divided by big N, because this is the number
in the entire population, whereas, this is the number in the sample. Now, this
might look Greek to you, well, it is. Sigma is the Greek letter capital S, which
makes sense because it means sum. When you see sigma and then x, this is then
telling you to add everything that comes after the sigma. And actually,
sometimes, there'll be a little i here. And this is going from i equals 1 to n,
meaning that we sum x1 plus x2 all the way to xn and then divide by the total
number. So, in this case this is x1, this is x2, x3, x4, and x5. And n is 5. So,
this is telling us that we sum everything from x1 all the way to xn. Now, don't
be intimidated by these symbols. In fact, I'm hoping that you're going to get
more and more comfortable with using symbols throughout the course. So that, by
the end, none of this seems intimidating. The reason I want you to feel
comfortable using symbols is because they're very important and they'll help you
with your mathematical thinking in every class. Symbols are like the alphabet.
The alphabet is basically symbols and we use these symbols to tell a story.
We've used them to learn about people from hundreds of years ago, who have
written their thoughts, in these symbols. Now, it's the same with Math. Except,
since Math is a different kind of language, we have different symbols. And Math
is a universal language. These symbols are used across the world, which is
really awesome. Mathematics is a way of thinking, and it has evolved over
thousands of years. And the way we symbolize these thoughts has evolved with it.
This statistical notation is shorthand instructions that tell us what to do.